faire un petit jeu pour l'association
pour give back charity jeux et jouets
qui tous les deux avec les mamans de
stars vous avez joué également
la photo de la mère d'une star qui va
apparaître à l'écran est en dessous il y
aura trois photos si vous trouvez ce qui
est son fils ou sa fille ouvre et
remporter 500 euros pour votre
association à chaque bonne réponse signe
d'accord alors attention par exemple
première question cette maman cette
maman est la maman de passe-partout
mimie mathy ou fabien lecoeuvre mieux at
il alors et vous n'aviez pas annoncé sa
partie de la famille pardon
passe-partout by matthew fabien
lecoeuvre qui est la personne la plus
vive le monsieur là pour l'enfant
mimie mathy battini la passerelle bonnes
réponses et marié n'a convaincu personne
attention il a cette maman est ce que
c'est la maman de m pokora julien doré
ou de jennifer assez facile très m
pokora julien doré ou jennifer à votre
ami dalida là elle a l'air bien calés
là-dessus non va pas
par moments j'ai cédé à huy duc et
jennifer et non c'était la mort de m
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui qui m'a dit voilà il dit vous
avez déjà ses difficultés
alors on va passer à la 4 cette
charmante dame est la mère de brad pitt
daniel craig ou de donald trump
daniel craig ou donald renault voilà
c'est qu'ils savent de qui ça donne un
indice c'est un acteur
[Applaudissements]
prénom c'est la 6 e cette dame est la
mère de patrick timsit
c'est la 6 florence foresti ou de dany
boon
regardez ils sont en train de le
chercher c'est la 6 merci ça c'est la
mère de full time et bien et vous
d'années est enfin là on va faire la
suite on en fait petite dernière on
termine avec cette dame selon vous il
s'agit de la mère de tom cruise george
clooney au bon goût des bacilles en
cause
je vous le dis on donne 5000 euros pour
la société
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]